They can laugh about it now, the Ohm family. It was Thanksgiving dinner, suburban Minneapolis, big spread, pumpkins on the table, 14 people. And it was 2002, the year after 9/11.
现在Ohm一家人已经能拿这件事开玩笑了。那是2002年，也就是9/11事件发生后的一年，在明尼阿波利斯郊区的一顿感恩节晚餐上，桌上摆满了南瓜，有14个人聚在一起。
And we were all just talking about 9/11, just 9/11 anything.
我们当时都在聊9/11，聊跟9/11有关的任何事情。
This is Alexis, the baby of the family. She and her parents came into our studio and talked with one of our show's producers, Alex Blumberg.
这是Alexis，家里最小的孩子。她和父母来到我们的演播室，与我们节目的制片人之一Alex Blumberg进行了交谈。
And one of the topics that was brought up was Osama bin Laden. And I, just for some reason, just said I thought he was attractive. I thought he was hot. And my dad really didn't appreciate that comment.
当时提到的一个话题是奥萨马·本·拉登。不知怎么的，我就说我觉得他很有魅力，我觉得他很帅。我爸爸当时真的很不喜欢这个评价。
I wasn't going to listen to any of it. I really wasn't. I mean, I wasn't going to let any comment like that, about his looks, get one inch further out of her mouth. I'll say to this day, it was ridiculous.
我当时根本听不进去，真的。我是说，关于他的长相，我绝不会让这种话从她嘴里再说出来。我至今仍坚持认为，那太荒唐了。
What did your father say?
你父亲说了什么？
I think he told me to [BLEEP] off.
我想他让我滚一边去。
That had never happened before. Alexis looked at her two little cousins, Henry and Hugo, who didn't know how to react. Her mom, Diane, didn't know how to react.
那种事以前从没发生过。Alexis看着她两个年幼的表亲Henry和Hugo，他们不知道该作何反应。她的妈妈Diane也不知道该怎么办。
I just saw my whole meal that I'd spent a week preparing kind of going up in flames with that statement. The minute the f-bomb landed I thought, well, now what am I going to do? There sat these two precious little boys. And their eyes were as biggest as saucers. I had a do something, anything to smooth this horrible situation over. So I think I probably said something like well, you know what? He does kind of look like Jesus, with the long hair. So just to smooth it over, that's what I remember myself saying.
我眼睁睁看着我花了一周准备的饭菜，因为那句话而泡汤了。在那句脏话出口的瞬间，我心想：好吧，我现在该怎么办？那两个珍贵的小男孩坐在那里，眼睛瞪得像铜铃一样大。我必须做点什么，任何能缓和这种可怕局面事。所以我可能说了一句类似这样的话：好吧，你们知道吗？留着长发的他看起来确实有点像耶稣。我记得我就是这么说的，纯粹是为了缓和气氛。
Yeah. Needless to say, comparing Osama bin Laden to Jesus didn't exactly smooth things over.
是啊，不用说，把奥萨马·本·拉登比作耶稣并没有起到缓和作用。
Then we all just started yelling.
然后我们大家都开始大喊大叫。
Yeah, I probably went to about 250 degrees.
是啊，我的火气估计飙升到了250度。
I think you got out of your chair.
我觉得你从椅子上站起来了。
I think I got out of my chair. I really did. I said if that's the best we can come up with after what's happened to our country, boy, I'll tell you.
我想我是站起来了。真的。我说，在我们国家发生了那样的事情之后，这就是我们能想出的最好评价吗？天哪，我告诉你们。
He was going off. And when Jeff goes off, we all listen. I do remember him saying something horrible like, I think the Middle East should be made into a parking lot.
他当时火冒三丈。当Jeff发火时，我们都会听着。我记得他说了一些很可怕的话，比如，我觉得应该把中东变成一个停车场。
I don't think I ever said that.
我不记得我说过那种话。
I think you did that day. Yes you did.
我觉得那天你确实说了。没错，你说了。
I guess in retrospect, my reaction I regret, for what I said. But I had to get my point across. I just, for some reason, had no appreciation for what Osama bin Laden looked like. This guy, I don't care what he looks like. I don't care if he looked like Paul Newman. He's still responsible for what he did. The looks things, it just jacked me right there.
回想起来，我对我说过的话感到后悔。但我必须表达我的观点。不知为什么，我对奥萨马·本·拉登的长相一点也不感冒。这家伙，我不在乎他长什么样。我不在乎他看起来是不是像保罗·纽曼。他依然要为他所做的一切负责。关于长相的那套说辞，简直让我气炸了。
Alexis pretty much knew what she was getting into talking about Osama bin Laden this way with her dad. He's conservative and served in the army. She knew what kind of room she was working. But she hadn't really factored in the fact that it was Thanksgiving dinner. Her dad says that a lot of what made it blow up.
Alexis其实很清楚，以这种方式和父亲谈论奥萨马·本·拉登会是什么后果。他是保守派，曾在军队服役。她知道自己面对的是什么样的人。但她确实没考虑到这是在感恩节晚餐上。她父亲说，正是这一点导致了冲突爆发。
That was just the wrong place at the wrong time. It really was. I think the tension of Thanksgiving, getting the food all on the table, getting prepared, getting going. And then all of a sudden, here we go.
那纯粹是错误的时间、错误的地点。真的。我想感恩节的紧张气氛、把食物端上桌、准备工作、忙碌奔波，然后突然间，就这样了。
Today on our show, we have stories of people facing various kinds of tough rooms. Trying to calculate what they're going to say, what they can get away with, and usually not getting the reactions they figured they were going to get. WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today. Tough Room in tough acts.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲一些人们面对各种“艰难局面”的故事。他们试图计算自己该说什么、可以侥幸说些什么，但通常得到的反应却与他们预想的截然不同。这里是WBEZ芝加哥，节目由公共广播国际发行。我是Ira Glass。我们今天的节目：艰难的局面与棘手的应对。
Act One, Make 'Em Laff, in which we go among comedy professionals who face a room that is so tough there is just one laugh every 100 jokes. Act Two, Bar Car Prophesy. A young person tries to hang out in a tough room full of adults-- adults and booze. Act Three, Mission: Impossible. At the doorsteps to one of the great secular temples to science ever built, New York's Museum of Natural History, two Mormon missionaries work a very tough sidewalk as they try to bring unbelievers over to their way of seeing things. Act Four, we go to the opposite of a tough room, the easiest room anywhere in this country. Well, maybe in this country isn't the right way to put it. Stay with us.
第一幕，“逗乐他们”，我们将走进那些面对极其尴尬场合的喜剧专业人士，在那里，可能每一百个笑话里只有一个能博得一笑。第二幕，“餐车预言”。一个年轻人试图混进一个全是成年人的尴尬圈子——到处是成年人和酒精。第三幕，“碟中谍”。在人类有史以来最伟大的世俗科学殿堂之一——纽约自然历史博物馆门口，两名摩门教传教士在一条非常难缠的人行道上工作，试图将不信教者引导向他们的世界观。第四幕，我们去往一个与艰难局面完全相反的地方，那是全国最容易搞定的场合。嗯，也许说“在这个国家”并不准确。请留下来继续收听。
Act One, Make 'Em Laff. There are tough rooms for salesmen, tough rooms for politicians, and tough rooms for teachers, and grant applicants, job interviewees, and doctoral students taking their orals. But I think the classic tough room, the tough room the defines them all, is when a comedian stands in front of a silent audience delivering one joke after another and getting nothing back whatsoever. And there's no tougher audience than other comedians.
第一幕，“逗乐他们”。对销售人员、政客、教师、奖学金申请者、求职面试者和进行口试的博士生来说，都有艰难的场合。但我认为，最经典的艰难局面，定义了所有这类尴尬的，就是当一名喜剧演员站在沉默的观众面前，一个接一个地讲笑话，却得不到任何反馈。而最难对付的观众，莫过于其他喜剧演员。
All right, here we go. Global warming proven by one 50-degree day in January. Area man just wants to know if he should cancel his annual Oscars party or not. Nation guesses it will have the chicken Caesar salad.
好了，开始吧。全球变暖被一月里那一天50度的天气证明了。当地居民只想知道是否该取消一年一度的奥斯卡派对。全国都在猜测这顿午餐会有凯撒鸡肉沙拉。
It's Monday morning in the offices of The Onion. And to start the new issue, each of the the writers has brought in a list of 15 headlines for their fake news newspaper. There are eight people at the table, seven men and one woman-- which is par for the course in the comedy business-- almost all of them are in their 20s.
周一早晨，《洋葱报》的办公室里。为了开始新的一期，每位作者都带了一份包含15条假新闻标题的清单。桌边坐着八个人，七男一女——这是喜剧行业常有的事——他们几乎都在20岁出头。
Seth Reiss goes first. He's just 24, been at the paper for two years. And the way it works is, if Seth can convince two people to vote for a headline, it survives one more day till the next round of editing.
Seth Reiss先来。他才24岁，在报社工作了两年。流程是这样的：如果Seth能说服两个人为某个标题投票，它就能存活到下一轮编辑。
Star of David to add seventh point. Report: America runs on--
大卫之星增加第七个点。报道：美国依靠……
Wait.  I'm sorry, it got enough votes. I just didn't understand why that was funny and I was going to ask for it.
等等，抱歉，这已经够票数了。我只是不明白为什么这很好笑，我本来想问问看的。
I just thinks it's silly.
我只是觉得这很蠢。
OK.  I'm just saying.
好吧，我只是说说而已。
The jokes survives. Seth marks it with a highlighter.
这个笑话存活了下来。Seth用荧光笔做了标记。
I came here because by the time they're done with this process, The Onion is one of the most reliably funny things out there. And I heard that one of the reasons for that was this room. It was a very tough room with a tough-minded editorial process that they'd been using for 20 years. And I wanted to see what that meant.
我来到这里是因为，在这个过程结束后，《洋葱报》通常是市面上最可靠的幽默刊物之一。我听说原因之一就是这个房间。这是一个非常严苛的场合，有着他们已经沿用了20年的严厉编辑流程。我想看看这意味着什么。
Car commercial pretty adamant about car.
汽车广告对汽车相当坚持。
Yeah.
没错。
Class struggle a breeze for local investment banker. Todd?
阶级斗争对当地投资银行家来说是小菜一碟。Todd？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Now you're just calling out who you want to vote for them? That's not right.
你现在是在直接点名要谁投票支持吗？那可不对。
Though it's incredibly popular-- with three quarters of a million copies in print each week, plus five million individual visitors at the website every month-- it's possible that, especially if you're older, you've never actually read The Onion. So here's what you need to know. It's written in newspaper form, though lots of the funniest stories aren't really new parody, but just everyday life described in a deadpan newspaper style. Like, "Stoners Announce Plans to Get Stoned for That," or "Rejection Letter Silently Flipped Off," or "Control of Anecdote Rested from Boyfriend." These were all considered for this one issue, by the way.
虽然它非常受欢迎——每周印刷发行75万份，每月有500万独立访问者——但有可能，特别是如果你年纪较大，你可能从未读过《洋葱报》。所以你需要了解这些：它以报纸的形式编写，尽管许多最有趣的报道并非真正的讽刺新闻，而只是以死板的报纸风格描述日常生活。比如，“瘾君子宣布计划为此去吸毒”，或者“拒绝信被无声地比出中指”，或者“男朋友手中的轶事控制权被夺走”。顺便说一下，这些都被列入过本期考虑范围。
The younger staffers say that it's hard not to take what happens in this room personally sometimes. Seth Reiss tells me that he's made a resolution to stop muttering under his breath, "you're all wrong" when the group rejects his headlines. Because, after all, they can't all be wrong.
年轻的工作人员说，有时候很难不把这个房间里发生的事情太个人化。Seth Reiss告诉我，他已经下定决心，当小组拒绝他的标题时，不再低声嘀咕“你们都错了”。因为毕竟，他们不可能全都错。
Megan Ganz, who is 23 and who's been at the paper for a year and a half, says it can be a blow, and it smarts when a headline that you're sure of, that you love, doesn't make the cut.
23岁的Megan Ganz已经在报社工作了一年半，她说当一个你确定、你喜爱的标题没能入选时，这确实是一个打击，而且很痛。
And it happens a lot. And then all of that work just evaporates into nothing. There are headlines that I remember pitching that I think I know that they're not any good. But some part of my heart is attached to them. Like I had this one that was "Spork Used as Knife." And for some reason, that was the funniest thing I thought I'd ever thought of, was the fact that here's a utensil that's two utensils. And you're using it as the only utensil it isn't. And it didn't even get a titter in the meeting. Just nothing, just died. And I read it twice, and they were like, yeah, move on. Then, still-- that must have been this summer-- it was like months ago that I wrote headline. I still think about it.
这种情况经常发生。所有的努力就这样化为乌有。我还记得我曾提出过一些我觉得不怎么样的标题，但我心中有一部分对它们很有感情。比如我曾有一个“叉勺被用作刀子”。不知为何，我觉得这是我能想到的最有趣的事，因为这是一个既是餐具又非餐具的餐具，而你把它当成了它唯一不是的那种餐具。结果会上连一声轻笑都没有。什么都没有，直接冷场。我读了两遍，他们就像是：好吧，跳过。直到现在——那应该是今年夏天的事了——那是几个月前写下的标题。我还是会想到它。
World's most depressing technical college creates world's most depressing bus ad. It's a slight variation on one that I've--
世界上最令人沮丧的技术学院制作了世界上最令人沮丧的公交广告。这是我之前的略微变体……
I still like that.
我还是喜欢那个。
I like that one.
我喜欢那个。
OK
好的。
The highlighter is passed to Todd Hanson, who's not just the oldest person at the table. He's been at The Onion longer than anybody else. He started in 1990, when The Onion wasn't really a business, but more of a hobby for a few friends who all worked crappy jobs elsewhere to support themselves.
荧光笔传到了Todd Hanson手里，他不仅是桌上年纪最大的人，在《洋葱报》待的时间也比谁都长。他始于1990年，那时《洋葱报》还算不上什么生意，更多是几个朋友的爱好，他们当时在别处干着烂工作来维持生计。
In these meetings, he tends to talk the most, partly out of seniority, and partly, as he admits, because he just can't be any other way. But when he reads his list, he's just like any of the other writers. And this is really the damnedest thing about their jobs-- even with all of his years of experience, even he can't tell which of his brand new jokes is any good.
在这些会议上，他倾向于发言最多，部分是因为资历，部分如他所承认的那样，是因为他就是改不了。但当他读自己的名单时，他和任何其他作者没什么两样。这就是他们工作中该死的地方——即使拥有这么多年的经验，即使是他，也无法判断他新想出的笑话哪一个好。
Man evidently think those sideburns make him look cool. That's not funny.
男人显然认为那些络腮胡让他看起来很酷。那一点都不好笑。
I kind of like that.
我倒挺喜欢那个。
Really?
真的吗？
Kind of.
算是吧。
Is it funny with something other than sideburns? No? OK. All right. Pornography desensitized populace demands new orifice to look at.
除了络腮胡，别的内容好笑吗？不？好吧。行。色情泛滥导致民众要求增加新的观赏孔。
Yes.
同意。
OK, area man not technically pathetic in that he fails to elicit pathos.
好的，当地男子在技术上并不算可怜，因为他无法引起同情。
But are you just making a joke about how people incorrectly use the word pathetic?
你只是在拿人们错误使用“可怜”这个词开玩笑吗？
It takes them two long mornings, on Monday and on Tuesday, to come up with the 16 headlines they're going to use in the paper this week. And to get to those 16 they go through-- and I know this number is going to sound kind of crazy-- 600 possible headlines.
他们花了两个漫长的早晨，周一和周二，才想出这周要在报纸上使用的16个标题。为了得到那16个，他们经历了——我知道这个数字听起来很疯狂——600个备选标题。
OK, this is a sad joke that come straight from real life. Casual relationship enters third year.
好了，这是一个直接来自现实生活的悲伤笑话。随意关系进入第三个年头。
So that's still going on?
所以那段关系还在继续？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. That wasn't to be mean. That was a legitimate question, because we've talked about it before.
抱歉，抱歉。我不是要刻薄。这是一个合法的问题，因为我们之前谈过它。
Truthfully, the staff was a lot nicer to each other than I figured they'd be. Comedians can be incredibly competitive. And The Onion has gone through phases when the chemistry wasn't so chill. But mainly, they're just tough on the material. It's a tough room because of how minutely they dissect all the jokes. Over the years, they've developed a way of discussing the material that helps them decide whether something is so outstanding funny, it beats a lot of other jokes that are also pretty funny, and what makes each joke funny, and how to make it funnier.
说实话，员工们彼此之间比我想象的要好得多。喜剧演员之间竞争可能非常激烈。而《洋葱报》也经历过团队氛围不太和谐的阶段。但总的来说，他们只是对素材很严苛。之所以是一个艰难的场合，是因为他们解剖所有笑话的方式极其细致。多年来，他们发展出一种讨论素材的方式，帮助他们决定某个东西是否好笑到足以击败其他同样有趣的笑话，以及是什么让每个笑话好笑，如何让它更好笑。
As an outsider, and not privy to the shared assumptions and what one of them called their hive mentality, it was sometimes hard to figure out why, for instance, "Local girlfriend always wants to do stuff," was a good enough headline to make it into paper, while a headline that seems nearly identical, "Nation's Girlfriends Call for More Quality Time," literally gets jeer-- jeers. Listen.
作为一个局外人，没有参与他们共享的预设，也没有参与其中一人所谓的“蜂群思维”，有时很难理解为什么，比如“当地女友总是想做这做那”是个足以入报的好标题，而一个看起来几乎一样的标题“全国女友呼吁更多高质量时间”却招来了嘲笑。听着。
Nation's girlfriends call for more quality time.
全国女友呼吁更多高质量时间。
Or nation's wives spend all the husband's money on expensive hat. Coming home with another round shaped box. Look at that stack of round boxes.
或者“全国妻子把丈夫的钱全都花在昂贵的帽子上”。带着另一个圆形的盒子回来。看看那堆圆盒子。
I'm pregnant.
我怀孕了。
Lucy!
Lucy！
Or why does this joke immediate, unquestioning approval?
或者为什么这个笑话能立即获得毫无疑问的批准？
Beauty regimen horrifying.
美容养生法很恐怖。
Yes.
同意。
Yes, definitely. That's funny.
好的，绝对同意。这很有趣。
While the headline "Roommate's unopened bag of Doritos taunting area man" deserved a long discussion of whether the point of the joke was, in fact, the taunting.
而标题“室友没开封的多力多滋袋子在嘲弄当地人”却需要一场关于笑话的重点是否真的是“嘲弄”的长篇大论。
The reason it's funny is because the word taunting--
有趣的原因是因为“嘲弄”这个词……
Like he's been staring at it from a distance of 15 feet from his couch for the past 10 minutes.
就像他过去10分钟一直从沙发上15英尺外盯着它看一样。
Or did the Doritos themselves make the joke too obvious?
或者多力多滋本身让笑话太显而易见了？
It's like, it would be funny and have funny details in it. But on its immediate surface, it's a joke about Doritos.
这就像，它会很有趣，里面也有有趣的细节。但在直接表面上，它是一个关于多力多滋的笑话。
I agree that Doritos has an immediate, go-to kind of snack. Is there another snack it could be?
我同意多力多滋是一种即时的、首选的小吃。还有其他零食可以替代吗？
I mean, Doritos is the exact right product.
我是说，多力多滋就是那个完美的产品。
Watching them parse jokes like this with a kind of academic precision they're sort of proud of, hour after hour, it's not just tedious. It's the opposite of comedy. And the other thing that was very odd watching them work was that most of the jokes that got the biggest laughs from the writers themselves did not make it into the paper. For example, this headline.
看着他们像对待学术研究一样以一种自豪的严谨性解析笑话，一小时又一小时，这不仅乏味。这简直是喜剧的反面。而观看他们工作时另一件非常奇怪的事情是，许多让写手们自己笑得最响的笑话并没有进入报纸。例如这个标题。
Cardinal teaches Pope to make church by interlocking his fingers.
红衣主教教教皇通过互锁手指来制作教堂。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Or this one.
或者这个。
No! That's so awful.
不！那太糟糕了。
Or here's another
或者这里还有个。
Infertile woman treats frog-shaped humidifier as human child.
不孕妇女把青蛙形状的加湿器当成人类孩子。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And, what the hell? Let's just do one more.
还有，管他呢？我们再试一个。
Biologist realizes he's been studying Cadbury Egg.
生物学家意识到他一直在研究吉百利复活节彩蛋。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
After the meeting, I get explanations for the many mysterious decisions I've witnessed. I'm told that usually the jokes that get laughs on Monday do not survive. Again, Megan Ganz.
会后，我得到了我所见证的许多神秘决定的解释。我被告知，通常周一让大家大笑的笑话无法存活。还是Megan Ganz。
A lot of the jokes that we laugh really hard at don't make it in the paper. Because they're just initially funny. But then we sit down on Tuesday and go, well, what does that mean though? Like, what do we say about that? Where does that joke go?
我们大笑的很多笑话没能进入报纸。因为它们只是初看好笑。但到了周二我们坐下来就会说：好吧，那意味着什么呢？我们要说什么？那个笑话往哪儿发展？
Like, there was a headline once that everyone laughed at really hard. It was, "Woman crying by penguin exhibit." Do you guys remember this headline? "Woman sobbing near penguin exhibit." And everyone laughed really hard. And then everyone went, OK, but why is that funny? It's funny because it's the penguins, I guess. And women crying is kind of a weird thing to be happening near them. But then nobody would pitch that on a Tuesday meeting as being funny. Even though it made everyone laugh, nobody would pitch that. What do you write about that? It doesn't go anywhere.
比如，曾有一个标题让所有人都笑得特别厉害。“企鹅展区旁的哭泣女子”。你们记得这个标题吗？“企鹅展区旁的哭泣女子”。大家都笑得很响。然后每个人都说，好吧，但那为什么好笑？我想是因为企鹅吧。而且女子在企鹅旁哭泣是一件很奇怪的事情。但后来周二会议上没人会把它作为笑话提出来。即使它让每个人都笑了，也没人会提。你能写什么？它没法展开。
And then there was this mystery. Why did this story "Local girlfriend always wants to do stuff" make the paper, while "Nation's girlfriends call for more quality time" got heckled? Todd Hanson and Dan Guterman explained that the story that went with "Local girlfriend always wants to do stuff" was actually written in a way that made fun of the guy in the relationship.
然后还有这个谜题。为什么“当地女友总是想做这做那”这个故事能入报，而“全国女友呼吁更多高质量时间”却被嘘？Todd Hanson和Dan Guterman解释说，与“当地女友总是想做这做那”配套的故事实际上是以一种嘲弄那段关系中的男方的方式写的。
And talking about what a sort of lowly loser he is for being irked by his girlfriend's desire to do things. It's just more like, she's always wanting to go do stuff, and be around people. She always wants to leave the house.
谈论他因为女友想做事而感到恼火，是个多么低级的失败者。更像是，她总是想去这做那，想和人在一起。她总是想离家出门。
And that seemed more original and different to us. Whereas, nation girlfriends-- what was it-- just seemed like a joke about nagging girlfriends.
这在我们看来更有原创性和不同点。而“全国女友”——那是什么——看起来就像是个关于唠叨女友的笑话。
And the problem with a joke about nagging girlfriends isn't the political correctness of it, but simply it's a really tired joke.
关于唠叨女友的笑话的问题，不在于政治正确与否，而仅仅是因为它是一个非常老套的笑话。
It's a really tired joke.
这真的是个老掉牙的笑话。
In fact, all through their editorial meetings, they're talking constantly about what jokes are tired. A joke about the Green Party and marijuana brownies was killed partly because mentioning the Green Party at all seem passe. A headline about Nicole Richie's new baby, "Nicole Richie thinks baby looks fat" was ditched on the theory that any Nicole Richie fat or anorexia reference was very 2005.
事实上，在他们的整个编辑会议中，他们一直在讨论哪些笑话是老套的。一个关于绿党和大麻布朗尼的笑话被毙掉，部分是因为提到绿党似乎已经过时了。一个关于妮可·里奇新宝宝的标题“妮可·里奇认为宝宝看起来很胖”被丢弃，理由是任何关于妮可·里奇肥胖或厌食症的引用都非常2005年。
But one area where tastes differ on the staff is when it comes to silliness. They're for silliness, sometimes. Take the joke, "Scientist Realizes He's Been Studying Cadbury Egg" that got such a big laugh on Monday. "It's just a silly joke," says Megan.
但员工中品味存在分歧的一个领域是关于“傻气”。他们有时支持傻气。拿那个在周一引发大笑的笑话“科学家意识到他一直在研究吉百利复活节彩蛋”来说。“那只是个傻笑话，”Megan说。
Like, we do silly jokes, granted. But it just doesn't have that x factor of being silly and kind of compelling. I don't know. I can't explain what the difference is between that one and-- we ran one that was "Thirsty mayor drinks town's entire water supply." And that one, we had the same reaction. When it was read, we laughed really hard. And then it went in the paper. And why is that one sillier and in a better way than the other one is silly? It's funny because it's almost always agreed upon in the meetings.
比如，我们确实会做傻笑话，承认这点。但它没有那种既傻又引人入胜的独特特质。我不知道。我无法解释那一个和——我们运行过一个叫“口渴的市长喝掉了城镇所有的水供应”之间的区别。那一个，我们有同样的反应。读到的时候，我们大笑不止。然后它就进了报纸。为什么那一个比另一个更傻、傻得更好？因为它在会议上几乎总是达成共识。
Almost, but not quite. When Todd Hanson and I sat down for an interview, he spontaneously brought up the exact same headline Megan had mentioned, though to made a very different point.
几乎，但不完全。当Todd Hanson和我坐下来接受采访时，他自发地提出了Megan提到的完全相同的标题，尽管他的观点完全不同。
No, no, no. Don't get me wrong. I like the silly jokes. I just have to think them through and find out what they're saying. Like I remember there was a joke, "Thirsty mayor drinks entire town's water supply." And just kept saying, why? What is it? Thirst guy drinks a whole lake? What's funny about that? It's just silly. It's silly in a way that isn't funny. And they're like, no, no. You have to trust us. Because he's the thirsty mayor. He drinks the whole town.
不，不，不。别误解我。我喜欢傻笑话。我只是必须把它们想透，找出它们在表达什么。比如我记得有个笑话，“口渴的市长喝掉了全镇的水供应”。我就一直在说，为什么？那是什么？渴了的人喝掉整个湖？那有什么好笑的？它只是傻。它的傻法并不好笑。他们说，不，不。你得相信我们。因为他是口渴的市长。他喝掉了整个镇子。
And they were trying to explain it to me. I just didn't get it. And then finally it clicked in my head. And I said oh, I get it. It's about misappropriation of public resources by a corrupt ruling oligarchy, or whatever. And then everyone made fun of me. Like, "Oh, yeah. That's what it's about. It's not just silly." Well, of course it's silly. But it has something to say, and that's why it's funny. That's what I think.
他们试图向我解释。我就是没懂。最后我脑子里闪过一个念头。我说，哦，我明白了。它是关于腐败的统治寡头阶层对公共资源的不当占用。然后每个人都嘲笑我。就像，“哦，是的。那就是它的意思。它不只是傻。”好吧，它当然傻。但它有话要说，这就是它好笑的原因。我是这么认为的。
I just don't think jokes that don't have anything to say are that funny. If you can't find something legitimate to say within the context of the joke, no matter how silly it is, I don't see the point of it.
我只是不觉得没话可说的笑话有那么好笑。如果你不能在笑话的语境下找到合法的东西来表达，无论它有多傻，我都看不出它的意义所在。
In fact, to sort this out, a whole language has emerged over the years at The Onion to talk about whether something is too silly or silly in the wrong way. Writers speak about a joke taking them to Sillytown, or Crazyville, or Sillytown Heights, which is either good or bad depending on the person.
事实上，为了理清这些，多年来《洋葱报》出现了一整套语言来讨论某事是否太傻或傻得不是地方。作者们谈论一个笑话把他们带到了“傻子镇”、“疯狂镇”或“傻子高地”，根据个人的不同，这可能是好事或坏事。
And it can be bad-- though it's usually good-- when something is called a Laffer. That's laffer with two F's. A laffer is a big dumb joke that you have to laugh at. If the photo that accompanies a story is a sandwich holding a press conference, that's a laffer. And the whole story is a laffertunity. Laffers are often the most emailed stories, the most popular things that The Onion does.
当某事被称为“Laffer”时，这可能是坏事——尽管通常是好事。“Laffer”指两个F的那个词。Laffer是一个你不得不笑的、又大又蠢的笑话。如果陪衬故事的照片是一个三明治在召开新闻发布会，那就是个Laffer。整个故事就是一个“Laffertunity”（笑话机遇）。Laffer往往是转发率最高的故事，是《洋葱报》做的最受欢迎的内容。
And while everybody on staff likes those silly jokes and jokes with a bigger meaning, a fewer of the younger writers definitely have more tolerance for jokes that are purely silly, and a different vision for what should go in the paper.
虽然所有员工都喜欢那些傻笑话和更有深意的笑话，但少数年轻作者绝对对纯粹傻的笑话有更高的容忍度，并且对应该放入报纸的内容有着不同的愿景。
And there were a couple times during the editorial meetings that I watched where the two sides squared off against each other. At one point, they were discussing two headlines that covered very familiar ground at The Onion . "Plan to stay in all weekend and play video games goes off smoothly," and "Area man makes it through day." Seth, one of the newest staffers, and Todd, the oldest, saw these very differently.
在我观察的编辑会议中，有几次双方发生了正面交锋。有一次，他们在讨论《洋葱报》非常熟悉领域的两个标题。“计划周末呆在家里玩游戏顺利进行”和“当地人撑过了一天”。Seth——最年轻的员工之一，和Todd——最年长的，对这两个标题的看法截然不同。
Especially the video game one. It seems very Onion by the numbers.
尤其是游戏那个。它看起来很像《洋葱报》流水线作品。
That's kind of why I liked it.
那正是为什么我喜欢它的原因。
I know. But I'll tell you, almost to a point where that sentiment, I don't think we're doing anything new there.
我知道。但我得告诉你，那个观点已经到了我不认为我们在那里做任何新东西的程度了。
I don't know, I just think of that as The Onion's ethos. That's kind of what The Onion is about. I mean, that's what America is.
我不知道，我只是把那看作《洋葱报》的精神。那正是《洋葱报》的意义所在。我是说，那才是美国。
I feel like you've done that joke before.
我觉得你以前做过那个笑话。
The reason we've done that joke before is because America has been like that for a long time. And it still is.
我们以前做过那个笑话的原因是，美国长期以来一直就是那样。而且现在依然如此。
But the sentiment is so similar to the sentiment of a lot of Onion headlines that people, they're not going to notice that. They're just going to be like, oh, The Onion does this again. I don't know. It just doesn't feel right.
但那种情绪和很多《洋葱报》标题的情绪太相似了，人们不会注意到这一点。他们只会觉得：哦，《洋葱报》又来了。我不知道。感觉不对劲。
Well, I'm going to keep writing jokes like that until the day I die. So I'm just warning you.
好吧，我死之前都会一直写那种笑话。所以先警告你们。
At the heart of this dispute is a problem that comes up in any creative project that lasts even a few years. You don't want to become a parody of yourself. You don't want to keep repeating the same things over and over. Yet there are some things you do a lot of, that are just built into the DNA of what you make.
这场争论的核心是任何持续几年以上的创意项目都会出现的问题。你不想成为你自己的模仿品。你不想一遍又一遍地重复同样的事情。然而，有些事情你做了很多次，它们已经融入了你作品的DNA中。
This is definitely something that we struggle with here on our radio show. And, in fact, The Onion once did an article that made fun of us for rehashing certain kinds of stories, which was funny. And it stung.
这绝对是我们节目在这里奋斗的事情。事实上，《洋葱报》曾经做过一篇文章取笑我们重炒某些类型的故事，这很有趣。而且很扎心。
Megan Ganz says that, as one of the newer writers on staff, she worries sometimes that they're just repeating the same jokes over and over with different words. There's the one, for instance, where a big government institution just acts like your schmo college roommate. Like, "Syria attends mideast peace talks for free continental breakfast". Funny, but it's a formula.
Megan Ganz说，作为报社较新的作者之一，她有时担心他们只是用不同的词一遍又一遍地重复同样的笑话。例如，有一个政府大型机构就像你那个混日子的室友。“叙利亚为免费欧式早餐参加中东和谈”。有趣，但这是一个公式。
And now they have, like with the youngs and olds, the problem is all of the young people grew up reading the stuff that the older people wrote. So we formed our sense of humor on The Onion , and then became writers for The Onion . You're trying to write for your idols. It's strange. It's strange for us. I know we've talked it many times, the young people here, it's strange for us to write for your idols.
现在他们像年轻人和老年人一样，问题是所有的年轻人都是读着老一代人写的东西长大的。所以我们的幽默感是在《洋葱报》上形成的，然后成了《洋葱报》的作者。你在为你崇拜的人写东西。这很奇怪。这对我们来说很奇怪。我知道我们谈过很多次，这里的年轻人，为你的偶像写东西很奇怪。
But also you're saying to Todd, who's been here forever, yeah, you can't do that again. Don't do that joke again. I'm tired of that joke.
但同时你还在对Todd说，那个待了很久的人：是的，你不能再那样做了。别再做那个笑话了。我厌倦了那个笑话。
That is really horrible, isn't it? So, I've been trying to mimic him throughout my life to get to where I am. And now that I'm where I am, I'm like, don't do what you do.
那真的很可怕，不是吗？所以，我一生都在试图模仿他以达到现在的地位。而现在当我到了这个地位，我就像：别做你做的事。
In the end, "Area man makes it through day" makes it onto a list of stories that will appear in upcoming issues of The Onion , partly because the founder and editor-in-chief of the paper, Scott Dikkers, liked it.
最后，“当地人撑过了一天”进入了将在《洋葱报》未来版本中出现的故事清单，部分原因是该报的创始人和主编Scott Dikkers喜欢它。
But this disagreement wasn't even close to the biggest fight they've all had lately. That fight, I'm told, was over the headline, "Ghost just dropped by to say boo." One group 100% hated it. One group 100% loved it. People raised their voices. One usually mild-mannered editor walked out in protest.
但这种分歧甚至不是他们最近发生过的最大争吵。我被告知，那次争吵是因为标题“幽灵刚刚顺道过来打个招呼”。一组人100%讨厌它。一组人100%喜欢它。人们提高了嗓门。一位通常脾气温和的编辑愤然离席以示抗议。
I guess people kind of read it as like a third grade joke book joke.
我想人们把它看作是小学笑话书里的笑话。
Editor Joe Randazzo says it was an existential fight about what kind of paper they were, that would or would not publish such a thing.
编辑Joe Randazzo说，这是一场关于他们是什么报纸的生存之战，关于出版或不出版这样的东西。
One member of staff may love The Onion that would never have "Ghost just dropped by to say boo," while another member of staff may love the fact that The Onion can include a joke that says, "Ghost just dropped by to say boo." It's totally subjective, though.
一名员工可能热爱绝不会有“幽灵顺道打招呼”这种笑话的《洋葱报》，而另一名员工可能热爱《洋葱报》能包含一个写着“幽灵顺道打招呼”的笑话。这完全是主观的。
Finally, the editor-in-chief had to tell everybody to cut it out. And they published the joke. And this one headline did not ruin the paper. But a room full of people who would even entertain the possibility that it might, who feel that strongly about it? That's a very tough room.
最后，主编不得不告诉大家停止争吵。他们发表了那个笑话。而这一个标题并没有毁掉报纸。但一个坐满了甚至会考虑这种可能性的、对此感觉如此强烈的人的房间？那是一个非常难缠的场合。
[MUSIC - "HA HA" BY HARPER SIMON]
（音乐 - Harper Simon的“Ha Ha”）
Act Two, Bar Car Prophesy. When you're a kid, adulthood itself can seem kind of a tough room, in which you're going to have to adapt to the strange custom that is the world of adults. But for Rosie Schaap, when she was a kid, the prospect of hanging with the adults seemed exciting, an adventure.
第二幕，“餐车预言”。当你还是个孩子的时候，成年本身看起来就是一个艰难的场合，你必须去适应那个叫做成人世界的奇怪习俗。但对于Rosie Schaap来说，当她还是个孩子时，与成年人在一起的前景看起来令人兴奋，是一场冒险。
1986, when I was 15, I discovered the bar car on the Metro-North New Haven Line, a dingy, crowded, badly-ventilated chamber where commuters drank enough to get a decent buzz going, told dirty jokes, and chain-smoked. These were my kind of people. And even though, in my memory, the whole place is covered in this sort of grimy, yellow film, it was my kind of joint.
1986年，我15岁时，我发现了大都会北方铁路纽黑文线上的餐车，一个肮脏、拥挤、通风不良的密闭空间，通勤者在那里喝得足够产生不错的微醺感，讲黄色笑话，并不停地抽烟。这些人是我的同类。尽管在我的记忆中，整个地方都覆盖着一层肮脏的黄色油膜，但它是我的乐园。
I took the train once a week from Westport, Connecticut to Manhattan's Grand Central Station to see my psychoanalyst. As self-absorbed as any teenager, I'd come to enjoy psychoanalysis. I'd been going since eighth grade, and the 50-minutes sessions made me feel like the featured guest on a talk show. It helped that my shrink sounded a lot like Dick Cavett.
我每周从康涅狄格州的韦斯特波特坐火车去曼哈顿的大中央车站见我的精神分析师。像任何青少年一样以自我为中心，我开始享受精神分析。我从八年级就开始去了，50分钟的疗程让我觉得自己像是脱口秀节目里的特邀嘉宾。而且我的心理医生听起来很像Dick Cavett，这很有帮助。
But from the moment I first stumbled into the bar car after one of our appointments, my return trip to Westport became the best part of my Thursday visits. I liked the company of grown ups, especially strangers. With them I found it easy to feel smart, and funny, and interesting.
但从我在预约后第一次跌跌撞撞进入餐车的那一刻起，回到韦斯特波特的往返旅程就成了我周四探访中最棒的部分。我喜欢成年人的陪伴，尤其是陌生人。和他们在一起，我很容易感到自己聪明、有趣、引人注目。
Once when I was eight and we were vacationing at the beach, my mother sent me to borrow a skillet from the neighbors, a bunch of 30-somethings in a shared rental. They were lounging on an L-shaped white couch and seemed to get a kick out of everything I said, even the word skillet. I wasn't even sure what the word meant until a tall woman handed me a heavy pan with flared sides. I thanked her and turned to leave.
有一次我八岁，我们在海滩度假，我母亲派我去邻居那儿借一个煎锅，那是几个合租的30岁左右的人。他们懒散地躺在L形的白色沙发上，对我说的任何话都感到很兴奋，甚至是“煎锅”这个词。在一位高个子女士递给我一个带有喇叭口沉重平底锅之前，我甚至不确定这个词是什么意思。我向她道谢，转身离开。
But they weren't ready to let me go. They had questions. Who was I? What grade was I in? What was I into? I was astonished by their interest. I sat myself down and asked if they wanted to hear a joke. "So this Jewish-American Princess married an Indian chief. Guess what they named their baby?" I paused for effect. "White fish." It's a terrible joke. I'd heard my mother tell it to one of her friends. I didn't exactly get it. But these grown ups, sitting there drinking wine, tumbled off the big white couch laughing. And I felt like a superstar.
但他们没准备让我走。他们有问题要问。我是谁？我几年级？我喜欢什么？我对他们的兴趣感到惊讶。我坐下来问他们想不想听个笑话。“所以这个犹太裔美国公主嫁给了一个印第安酋长。猜猜他们给孩子取什么名字？”我停顿一下制造效果。“白鱼。”这真是一个糟糕的笑话。我听我妈给朋友讲过。我并没完全明白笑点。但这些坐着喝葡萄酒的成年人从巨大的白色沙发上笑得跌了下来。而我觉得自己像个超级巨星。
That's how I wanted to feel in the bar car surrounded by its regulars, mostly men in wrinkled suits and loosened neckties. I liked listening to them. They drank beer or Scotch, laughed loudly, talked fast, and always seemed happy to see each other. They were a tribe, and I wanted in. Still, I didn't dare pony up to the bar and order myself a beer. There was no way the weary Metro-North crew would serve me. I needed a point of entry.
这就是我想在餐车里，在那些常客——大多是穿着皱巴巴西装、解开领带的男人——中间感受到的。我喜欢听他们说话。他们喝啤酒或苏格兰威士忌，大声笑，说话很快，而且看起来总是很高兴见到对方。他们是一个部落，而我想加入。尽管如此，我不敢走到吧台前给自己点一杯啤酒。大都会北方的疲惫工作人员绝不会给我服务。我需要一个切入点。
I found what I was looking for the night I pulled my Tarot cards for my backpack and gave myself a reading right there in the bar car. I'd been studying The Pictorial Key to the Tarot, a 1910 primer by Arthur Edward Waite, and had cultivated a look that fell somewhere between Janis Joplin and Madame Blavatsky. Gauzy Indian dresses, [? batik ?] kaftans, chunky silver rings on my fingers. My Tarot cards smelled of patchouli and sandalwood, cigarettes and pot. I shuffled and then began to lay them out in the Celtic cross pattern I'd learned from Waite's book. First the significator, the card that stood for me. Then the card that crossed me, signifying the things that blocked my path. Next the card that crowned me, representing my ideals and aims. And so on and so on, until I laid out the 10th and final card, which would reveal the answer to my question.
那个晚上，当我从背包里拿出塔罗牌，就在餐车里为自己算了一卦时，我找到了我想要的东西。我一直在研究《塔罗牌图解》，那是Arthur Edward Waite在1910年写的一本入门书，并培养了一种介于Janis Joplin和Madame Blavatsky之间的装扮。轻飘飘的印第安裙子，扎染卡夫坦长袍，手指上戴着笨重的银戒指。我的塔罗牌闻起来有广藿香和檀香、香烟和大麻的味道。我洗了洗牌，然后开始按Waite书里学到的凯尔特十字阵型把它们摊开。首先是“指示牌”，代表我的牌。然后是挡路牌，象征阻碍我道路的事物。接着是冠顶牌，代表我的理想和目标。以此类推，直到我放下第10张也是最后一张牌，它将揭示我问题的答案。
By then, a small crowd had gathered around me. When I finished, a woman asked if I'd give her reading. It was the first time someone in the bar car had spoken to me without wanting to see my ticket. She asked what I charged. I hadn't thought about that. I mulled it over and told her I thought it was kind of bad mojo to take money for readings. But I was cool with bartering. And I wouldn't mind a beer. She didn't ask how old I was.
到那时，一小群人聚集在我身边。当我结束时，一位女士问我是否能为她算算。这是餐车里第一次有人跟我说话而不是为了看我的票。她问我收费多少。我还没想过那个问题。我琢磨了一下，告诉她我觉得收钱算卦有点招霉运。但我可以用以物易物的方式。我不介意来杯啤酒。她没问我多大。
Her reading was good, mostly positive cards. Yes, I told her, she would thrive at her new job. She might even get a promotion soon. She smiled and discreetly got me that beer. Suddenly it was like a divination marathon. I must have done five readings in an hour. The more I read, the more confident I grew. A routine took shape. As I laid down the cards, I'd sing Neil Young's "After the Gold Rush" quietly, almost under my breath.
为她算的牌很好，大多是积极的。是的，我告诉她，她会在新工作中蓬勃发展。她甚至可能很快获得晋升。她笑了笑，悄悄给我弄来那杯啤酒。突然间，这就像是一场占卜马拉松。我大概在一小时内做了五次算命。我算得越多，就越自信。一种惯例形成了。当我放下牌时，我会低声唱着尼尔·杨的《金矿之后》，几乎是在自言自语。
Then, when I was done, I'd give the whole pattern an initial once over and look solemnly into the questioner's eyes. "The cards are here to guide us," I'd say in a voice an octave lower than my own. "But what they tell us is not carved in stone. You have the power to change any of this." And all these grown ups-- accountants, lawyers, executives-- hung on my every word.
然后，完成后，我会对整个牌阵初步观察一番，并深沉地凝视提问者的眼睛。“牌在这里指引我们，”我会用比平时低八度的声音说，“但它们告诉我们的并非刻在石头上。你有权改变这一切。”而所有这些成年人——会计师、律师、高管——都倾听我的每一句话。
The next week, after therapy, my fortune telling for alcohol scheme began in earnest. Again I settled into the bar car and gave myself a reading. And again, a cluster of commuters assembled around me. I felt like I'd cracked a code. They'd sit down next to me and listen obediently. "When you shuffle the cards, put your energy into them. Concentrate on your question," I instructed them. "If you're doing this half-heartedly, the cards will know."
下周，疗程结束后，我的“算命换酒”计划正式开始了。我再次坐进餐车，为自己算了一卦。同样的，一群通勤者聚集在我身边。我觉得自己破解了一个密码。他们会坐在我旁边服从地听着。“当你洗牌时，把你的能量注入其中。集中注意力在你的问题上，”我指导他们，“如果你心不在焉，牌会知道的。”
This continued for weeks, and out of it I got plenty of beer, a couple of books, a pair of silver earrings. That, and the undivided attention of all these adults. I'd explain what each position in the Celtic cross meant, the significance of casting more cups than swords, more wands than pentacles. If someone's reading turned up an unusually high number of Major Arcana cards, I'd go quiet for a moment before I disclosed to him how much power that foretold, and urged him to use that power responsibly, for the greater good.
这种情况持续了数周，从中我得到了充足的啤酒、几本书、一副银耳环。除此之外，还有所有这些成年人的全神贯注。我会解释凯尔特十字阵中每个位置的含义，铸造更多圣杯胜过宝剑、更多权杖胜过星币的意义。如果某人的牌出现了异常多的大阿尔克那牌，我会安静片刻，然后向他透露这预示着多大的权力，并敦促他为更大的利益负责任地使用这种力量。
I never asked them their names, and I never told them mine, not my real one anyway. Yet time after time, as I laid out their futures, complete strangers would drop intimate clues about their lives, their jobs, their families. More than once a wingtip wearing banker or salesman confided in me that he'd taken acid and sloshed around in the mud at Woodstock, and felt very connected to the energy of the universe. I'd nod and say something like, "That's awesome, man. I wish I'd been there."
我从没问过他们的名字，也从没告诉过他们我的名字，至少不是真实的那一个。然而一次又一次，当我摊开他们的未来时，完全陌生的人会透露关于他们生活、工作、家庭的私密线索。不止一次，穿着翼纹皮鞋的银行家或推销员向我吐露，他曾在伍德斯托克吸食迷幻药，在泥泞中翻滚，并感到与宇宙的能量紧密相连。我会点点头说类似“太棒了，伙计。真希望我也在那儿”之类的话。
It was as if I'd materialized before their eyes, like some ghost from their youth come back to answer questions about their future.
就像我出现在他们眼前，就像他们年轻时的一个幽灵回来回答关于未来的问题。
Of course, there were people in the bar car who paid me no mind, and others who made their skepticism known. But I was dismissive of the nonbelievers. They were out of touch, and that was their loss. Still, one heckler in the crowd made me nervous.
当然，餐车里也有人完全不理我，还有些人表现出怀疑。但我对那些不信的人嗤之以鼻。他们与世隔绝，那是他们的损失。不过，人群中一个嘘声者让我感到紧张。
I couldn't pinpoint his age, mid-30s I guessed. He was a broad-shouldered, thick-necked guy with a beer gut, strawberry blond hair, and a big, ruddy face. He looked like a Kennedy, but you couldn't quite put your finger on which one. And did he have a mouth on him. The F word used as a noun, verb, and adjective strung together in one sentence, and then the next, and the next, like artillery fire. The guy was always drunker and louder than anyone else. Once, he cupped his hands into a makeshift megaphone and sort of stage-shouted at me something like, "The '60s are over. Get a life." As much as I basked in my bar car celebrity, I dreaded seeing that guy.
我说不清他的年龄，猜是30岁出头。他是一个宽肩膀、粗脖子、有啤酒肚、有着草莓金色头发、红润脸庞的家伙。他看起来像个肯尼迪家族的人，但你说不出到底是哪一个。而且他的嘴巴很坏。F开头的脏话被用作名词、动词和形容词连在一起放在一个句子里，然后是下一个，再下一个，就像炮火一样。这家伙总是比任何人都醉得厉害，叫得更大声。有一次，他把双手叠成临时的扩音器，冲我大喊大叫，大概是：“60年代结束了。找点正事做吧。”尽管我沉浸在餐车的名气中，但我很怕见到那个家伙。
And then one Thursday, after I had already served a few of my patrons, he half-staggered, half-swaggered over to me. "All right," he said. "This is total BS. But go ahead. Do mine."
然后有一个周四，我已经为几位顾客服务后，他摇摇晃晃地向我走来。“好吧，”他说，“这完全是胡扯。但接着吧。算算我的。”
He plunked himself down across from me, his knees a little too close. I wanted to tell him to go away. I wanted to tell him that his unwillingness to believe would insult the spirits and make them uncooperative. But I worried he'd call me a fraud.
他一屁股坐在我对面，膝盖离我太近了。我想让他走开。我想告诉他，他不愿相信的态度会侮辱灵体，使它们不配合。但我担心他会说我是骗子。
I played it cool and started my spiel. Shuffle, focus, give the cards your energy. He rolled his eyes but played along. He cut the cards once and handed me the deck. I laid them out. First, I set down his significator, the 10 of swords. Possibly the worst card of all, with a solitary, prostrate figure under a black sky pierced in the back by all 10 swords. It represents, in Waite's words, pain, affliction, sadness.
我保持镇定，开始了我的说辞。洗牌，集中注意力，把你的能量给牌。他翻了个白眼，但还是配合了。他切了一次牌，把牌递给我。我摊开了它们。首先，我放下了他的指示牌，宝剑十。可能是所有牌中最糟糕的一张，一个孤独的、俯卧的人影在黑暗的天空下，背上被10把宝剑刺穿。用Waite的话说，它代表痛苦、折磨、悲伤。
The rest of the cards weren't much better. He pulled the tower, a card signaling corruption, destruction, and the presence of evil. He got the death card, too. And as much as I disliked the guy, I really didn't like what I saw in those cards, not for anyone. Not even for him.
其余的牌也好不到哪儿去。他抽到了塔牌，一张预示腐败、毁灭和邪恶存在的牌。他也抽到了死神牌。尽管我不喜欢这个家伙，但我真的不喜欢我在这些牌中看到的东西，不是对任何人。甚至对他也不行。
I kept quiet for a long minute while I tried to figure out how to spin this. But there was nothing good I could say. Maintaining eye contact is key to being a good mystic, but I couldn't even meet his gaze. "Well, what's it say?" he finally asked. I took a deep breath. "None of this is carved in stone or written in blood." He cut me off. "Well, what?"
我沉默了良久，试图想出如何圆这个局。但没什么好话可说。保持眼神交流是成为优秀神秘学家的关键，但我甚至不敢迎上他的目光。“好吧，上面说了什么？”他最后问道。我深吸一口气。“这些没有什么是刻在石头上或写在血里的。”他打断我，“那到底是什么？”
So I told him what I saw. And as I interpreted one dismal symbol after another, the guy leaned in closer, put his elbows on the table, buried his head in his hands, and started to cry.
所以我告诉了他我看到了什么。当我解释一个又一个阴郁的象征时，这家伙倾过身子，把手肘放在桌子上，把头埋在手里，开始哭泣。
He told me that his marriage was falling apart, that he constantly worried about his health, that he was too young for heart problems, but he had them. That he felt as though his life had added up to zero. He asked, "Will I ever be happy?" "The cards," I answered bluntly, "said no. But," I told him, just like I told everyone else, "you have the power to change that." He shook his head and glared at me with red swollen eyes that said he did not.
他告诉我他的婚姻正在分崩离析，他一直担心自己的健康，他对于心脏问题来说太年轻了，但他确实有。他觉得自己的生活加起来等于零。他问：“我还会快乐吗？”“牌，”我直截了当地回答，“说了不。但是，”我告诉他，就像我告诉其他人一样，“你有权改变这一点。”他摇了摇头，用红肿的眼睛瞪着我，表示他没有。
Maybe he didn't. Maybe no one had the power. Maybe the days that lie ahead of us are set in stone, and that was that. And maybe I'd been the cynic. Something I had believed in had become a gambit for attention. I hadn't thought it though. And maybe I'd even hurt people.
也许他确实没有。也许谁都没有那种力量。也许我们面前的日子是刻在石头上的，就是那样。也许我一直是个愤世嫉俗者。我曾经相信的东西变成了一个博取注意的策略。我没想清楚。甚至可能还伤害了别人。
In the background, other passengers were caught up in conversation, laughing and drinking and carrying on. I could think of nothing more to say to the guy, nothing reassuring. I felt small and foolish. And when the guy finally got off the train a couple of stops before mine, I was relieved.
背景里，其他乘客正沉浸在交谈中，大笑、喝酒、嬉闹。我看着这个家伙想不出什么可说的，没什么安慰的话。我觉得自己渺小而愚蠢。当那个家伙在离我两站路的地方下车时，我松了一口气。
I sat awake in my bed that night and thought about him. I imagined him going home to a white clapboard colonial, to an unhappy wife pretending to be asleep. I imagined him returning the next day to a job he hated and getting wasted again that afternoon. But of course, at 15, I couldn't imagine what it was like to be him, to live his life. And I realized I didn't want to be able to. Reading Tarot cards in the bar car had been fun until it got serious. Adults had problems I could not begin to fathom. And they had things to say I wasn't ready to hear.
那天晚上我躺在床上没睡，想着他。我想象他回到一栋白色的木瓦殖民地风格房子里，面对一个假装睡着的、不幸福的妻子。我想象他第二天回到一份他讨厌的工作中，下午再次烂醉如泥。但当然，15岁时，我无法想象成为他、过他的生活是什么样子。我意识到我不想能想象。在餐车里算塔罗牌曾经很有趣，直到它变得严肃。大人们有着我无法理解的问题。而且他们说的话我还没准备好去听。
I didn't go back to the bar car. I missed the grown ups. I missed their attention. But I was not one of them. I didn't belong there. Although I could feel adulthood encroaching-- real adulthood, which now seemed less about drinking and smoking and freedom, and more about loss, and fear, and the sense that death, itself, lay waiting somewhere just ahead.
我没再回餐车。我怀念那些成年人。我怀念他们的关注。但我不是他们的一员。我不属于那里。尽管我可以感觉到成年正在逼近——真正的成年，现在看起来不再是关于喝酒、抽烟和自由，而是更多关于失去、恐惧，以及死亡本身正潜伏在前方不远处的感觉。
Rosie Schaap. This story comes from a book of essays that she's writing about drinking called Drinking With Men . It comes out next year.
Rosie Schaap。这个故事来自她正在撰写的关于饮酒的文集《与男人共饮》。明年出版。
Coming up, if Jerry Seinfeld became a Mormon tomorrow, the most likely way that it would happen would be because of two guys that we are going to introduce you to. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，如果Jerry Seinfeld明天成了摩门教徒，最可能的原因将是我们要介绍给你的两个人。那是芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际带来的节目，我们的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Hello? Hello? Hello? Anybody out there? OK, if you're out there, make a noise. Tough room. That's our theme. It's very clever how we do this here on the public radio.
这里是《美国生活》，我是Ira Glass。每周我们的节目，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种各样的关于那个主题的故事。喂？喂？喂？有人吗？好了，如果你们在那儿，发点声音。艰难的场合。这就是我们的主题。我们在公共广播里做这个的方式非常聪明。
We've arrived at act three of our show, Act Three, "Mission Impossible." In the Bible, God is constantly sending his prophets into situations where nobody wants to hear what they have to say. And after high school, young Mormon men are basically supposed to do the same thing. They are encouraged to go on a two-year mission to spread the gospel. They pay their own way.
我们到达了节目的第三幕，第三幕，“碟中谍”。在圣经里，上帝总是把他的先知送到那些没人想听他们说话的地方。高中毕业后，年轻的摩门教男人基本上也应该做同样的事情。他们被鼓励进行为期两年的传教，传播福音。他们自己承担费用。
Jane Feltes followed two of these guys, out to convert people in a place that we usually don't think up as a bastion of Mormonism, or particularly friendly to missionaries, the Upper West Side of Manhattan.
Jane Feltes跟随了其中的两个人，去那些我们通常不认为是摩门教堡垒或对传教士特别友好的地方——曼哈顿上西区——进行劝说。
Elder [? Longey ?] -- Elder doesn't mean older; it's just a title given to missionaries-- is 20, an army brat most recently from Utah. Elder [? Mellor ?] is from Utah too. And he's 21. They're both in the second year of their mission, so they kind of have it down.
Elder Longey——Elder并不意味着更年长；这只是给予传教士的一个头衔——20岁，最近刚从犹他州过来的军人家庭的孩子。Elder Mellor也来自犹他州。他21岁。他们都在传教的第二年，所以他们算是有经验了。
How you doing today, sir? Have you ever had the chance to read the Book of Mormon? No chance? All right, do you know anyone in the area we can share our message about Christ with?
你好，先生，今天怎么样？你有机会读过《摩门经》吗？没机会？好的，你知道附近有谁我们可以分享关于基督的信息吗？
The guy literally tells him, "get lost".
那家伙直接告诉他：“滚开”。
You don't know anybody in the area we can do some service for? All right, you have a great day, sir.
你不知道附近有谁我们可以提供服务的吗？好的，祝你有美好的一天，先生。
Today they're stopping people outside the American Museum of Natural History, but they work all over New York and its suburbs. And the toughest thing about being a missionary in New York isn't what you might think-- that it's too secular, or too Jewish, or too unfriendly, or too cool for school, especially Sunday school. No. The problem is competition. In New York, there are so many distractions on the street, people trying to hand you fliers or get you into their hair salon or comedy show.
今天他们在美国自然历史博物馆外拦人，但他们在纽约及其郊区到处工作。在纽约做传教士最难的事情不是你可能想到的——它太世俗，或太犹太，或太不友好，或对学校，尤其是主日学太酷。不。问题是竞争。在纽约，街上的干扰太多了，到处是试图递给你传单或带你进美发沙龙或喜剧表演的人。
If you're saying no to someone who asks, "Do you have one minute to save the environment?" you're not going to say yes to these guys.
如果你对那些问“你有一分钟来拯救环境吗？”的人说不，你也不会对这些人说是。
Everyone's walking down the street, and everybody's walking about the same pace. And anything that will disrupt the flow will cause them to be angry. Just because they're already in the mindset that they're going somewhere, anything that stops them is going to make them angry. Usually we're the ones that stop them. We're usually that disruption.
每个人都在街上走着，而且步伐差不多。任何会打乱流程的事情都会让他们生气。仅仅因为他们已经处于要去某处的思维模式中，任何阻止他们的事都会让他们生气。通常我们就是那个阻止他们的人。我们通常就是那个干扰。
Both guys are living off their savings while they're here. Elder [? Longey ?] lives in Chinatown with three other missionaries in a two bedroom apartment. Elder [? Mellor's ?] two bedroom in Harlem houses six missionaries. And for 12 hours every day, from 9:00 AM to 9:00 PM, most of their interactions are less than 30 seconds, if you'd even call them interactions.
两个家伙住在这里的时候都靠积蓄生活。Elder Longey和另外三名传教士住在唐人街的一套两居室公寓里。Elder Mellor在哈莱姆的两居室里住了六名传教士。每天12个小时，从早上9点到晚上9点，他们的大部分互动不到30秒，如果那甚至能被称为互动的话。
Hey, sister.
嘿，姐妹。
Elder [? Mellor ?] calls out to a cute woman in her late 20s.
Elder Mellor对着一位20多岁可爱的女士喊道。
Have you ever seen this picture before?
你见过这张照片吗？
Sorry?
抱歉？
He shows her a picture of Jesus baptizing Peter on the cover of his Book of Mormon.
他给她看了一张耶稣在《摩门经》封面上给彼得施洗的照片。
Have you ever see this picture before?
你见过这张照片吗？
Yes, I have.
是的，我见过。
That's good. We want to invite you to be baptized by that same authority that he's given.
那太好了。我们想邀请你接受同样由他授予的权威施洗。
I'm Christian, I don't know.
我是基督徒，我不确定。
Yeah, we are too.
是的，我们也是。
All right. But I'm not Mormon. Thank you though.
好的。但我不是摩门教徒。不过谢谢。
"I'm not Mormon," she says. "Thank you though."
“我不是摩门教徒，”她说，“不过谢谢。”
I wouldn't talk to you if you were Mormon, right? Where you from?
如果你们是摩门教徒我才不会跟你们说话，对吧？你们从哪儿来的？
She's gone within seven seconds. Par for the course, says Elder [? Longey ?].
她七秒钟就走得没影了。Elder Longey说，这很正常。
I don't know if you saw. But when people say no and we're still trying to talk to them, we're just trying different things. "No, I don't want that." "Do you know anyone who does want it?" "No, I don't know. "Well do you know anybody who wants to come to church?" "No, I don't know anybody." "Well, do you want to come to church?"
不知道你有没有看到。但当人们说不，我们还在试着跟他们说话时，我们只是在尝试不同的东西。“不，我不想要那个。”“你知道有谁想要吗？”“不知道。”“那你知道有谁想去教堂吗？”“不知道。”“那你想去教堂吗？”
And then they walk away and you feel what?
然后他们走开了，你感觉如何？
And I feel, I don't know. That guy really doesn't want to go to church. Sometimes I get defensive. Under my breath I'll mutter something.
我觉得，不知道。那家伙真的不想去教堂。有时我会防御心很强。我会嘀咕点什么。
Elder [? Longey, ?] did you ever get the my baby's sleeping, I have to go watch it?
Elder Longey，你有没遇到过“我宝宝在睡觉，我得去看着它”之类的借口？
Oh, yeah.
哦，有。
I hate that. It's like, it's sleeping. You don't need to watch it.
我讨厌那个。就像，它在睡觉。你不需要看着它。
Yeah, excuses.
是的，借口。
Hey, brother, how you feeling today?
嘿，弟兄，今天感觉如何？
How are you doing today, brother?
你好吗，弟兄？
Hey, sisters, can we invite you guys to get your Mormon on by--
嘿，姐妹们，我们可以邀请你们加入摩门教吗，通过……
Calling everybody brother and sister was not working at all for them.
称呼每个人弟兄和姐妹对他们来说根本没用。
Have a good one.
祝你有愉快的一天。
I figured it had to be a Mormon thing. It turns out, it's not.
我以为那一定是摩门教的习惯。事实证明，不是。
I picked that up in the Bronx. "Hey, what's up brother?" Usually in the Bronx they're like, "Hey, what's up?" They'll like say it back.
我在布朗克斯学到的。“嘿，怎么了弟兄？”通常在布朗克斯，他们会像这样，“嘿，怎么了？”他们会回应。
This definitely ain't the Bronx, though. Right across the street lives Jerry Seinfeld, Glenn Close, John McEnroe, and Helen Gurley Brown. Which makes it the toughest kind of neighborhood for missionaries. In the Bronx, people will talk to them, let them visit their homes. But the wealthier the area, they say-- like here on Central Park West-- it's a much harder sell.
但这里绝对不是布朗克斯。就在街对面住着Jerry Seinfeld、Glenn Close、John McEnroe和Helen Gurley Brown。这使它成为传教士最难缠的社区。在布朗克斯，人们会和他们说话，让他们去家里探访。但在越富裕的地区，他们说——就像中央公园西路这里——销售难度就大得多。
Spreading the word about Mormonism is a numbers game. And to talk to the greatest number of people in a day in New York City, the guys have each learned how to strike up a conversation in at least five different languages. Elder [? Longey ?] approaches a man sitting on the steps.
传播摩门教信息是一场数字游戏。为了在纽约市一天内与尽可能多的人交谈，他们每个人都学会了用至少五种语言开启对话。Elder Longey接近一个坐在台阶上的男人。
Donde vive? In Manhattan?
在哪儿住？在曼哈顿吗？
Brooklyn.
布鲁克林。
Brooklyn, que parte?
布鲁克林，哪个区？
Elder [? Mellor ?] hears a woman speaking French to her child.
Elder Mellor听到一位女士用法语对孩子说话。
En Francais? Believe de Mormon? Au revoir.
用法文？相信摩门教？再见。
And Elder [? Longey ?], he even knows some sign language.
Elder Longey甚至会一点手语。
My sign language is improving.
我的手语在进步。
Over the course of the afternoon, approaching every person who walks by, they get a couple dozen cards with the church's address into people's hands. They say, on average, they manage to get about three or four new people to come to church each week, which seems amazingly low given that it's two of them working basically every waking minute.
整个下午，接近每个路过的人，他们发出了十几张带有教堂地址的卡片。他们说，平均每周他们能成功让三到四名新成员来教堂，考虑到他们两个基本上每醒着的一分钟都在工作，这看起来低得惊人。
Are these skills that you're learning out here these few years, are they things you think you're going to take into your career?
你们在这几年学到的这些技能，你们认为会带入你们的职业生涯吗？
Yes.
是的。
Most definitely.
绝对会。
What are you going to do?
你们打算做什么？
I thought about it. I was like, I bet selling life insurance is way easier than this. Because I've met people who do sell life insurance.
我想过这个问题。我心想，我打赌卖人寿保险比这个简单多了。因为我见过卖人寿保险的人。
They're happy people.
他们是快乐的人。
They're very successful. I wonder what I could do if I did that. Or those guys who sell scissors, going door to door. Like CUTCO. They sell scissors. I'm like, I'm sure I can sell some scissors. Sometimes I think I could sell scissors better than that guy. Because you know how to do deal with people turning you  down. Even if you get turned down over and over again, it's finding that little thing that keeps you going, that little thing that keeps you talking to people.
他们非常成功。我想如果我做那个我能做什么。或者那些挨家挨户卖剪刀的家伙。比如Cutco。他们卖剪刀。我心想，我肯定能卖出一些剪刀。有时我觉得我能比那个家伙卖得更好。因为你知道怎么处理人们拒绝你。即使你被一次又一次拒绝，你还是能找到那个让你坚持下去的小东西，那个让你继续和人交谈的小东西。
But in this, that little things that keeps you going is like eternal life. With scissors, I don't know.
但在传教中，那个让你坚持下去的小东西是永恒生命。卖剪刀，我不知道。
I don't know, paycheck. I don't know.
不知道，工资支票。不知道。
While I'm with them, their longest conversations are with guys who seem down on their luck. One guy might have been drunk. And another guy who, if he wasn't homeless, was probably often mistaken for homeless. And they spend even more time with people they have no hope of baptizing, like this guy.
我跟着他们的时候，他们最长的谈话是和那些看起来境遇不佳的人进行的。有一个家伙可能是喝醉了。另一个如果不是无家可归，也经常被误认为是无家可归。他们花更多时间与那些他们根本没希望施洗的人在一起，比如这个家伙。
Here you go, last one. I don't like the way they translated this, but OK.
给你，最后一个。我不喜欢他们翻译这个的方式，但还行。
Elder [? Mellor ?] is standing talking to a middle-aged Orthodox Jewish man in a navy trench coat and hat. The two men get into a long, in-depth discussion about religion, specifically whether, as the Mormons believe, a prophet walked the earth in America in the 1800s.
Elder Mellor正站在那里和一个穿着海军蓝风衣和戴着帽子的中年东正教犹太人交谈。两人进行了一场深入、详尽的宗教讨论，特别是在摩门教相信先知曾在1800年代在美国行走于世这一点上。
What about Jeremiah and things like that?
关于耶利米之类的人呢？
In dreams. They had dreams. God did not speak to them
在梦里。他们做了梦。上帝并没有对他们说话。
Right. Our message is that God has a prophet on the earth again.
对。我们的信息是上帝再次在地球上有了先知。
There are many prophets.
先知有很多。
This is true. But there are those ordained, like Moses.
确实。但有一些是受过圣职的，像摩西那样。
It was like watching a couple of football fans talk about the Superbowl, even though they were rooting for different teams. They know they'll never convince the other that their team is better. But they're really enjoying the back and forth. They seem relieved to have found someone who relates to the world the way they do.
这就像看几个橄榄球迷讨论超级碗，尽管他们支持不同的球队。他们知道永远无法说服对方他们的球队更好。但他们真的很享受这种往返交流。他们似乎很高兴找到了一个看待世界方式相同的人。
God bless you.
上帝保佑你。
You too, brother. Have a good one.
你也是，弟兄。祝你有愉快的一天。
I think some of my favorite people I like talking to, I like talking to Jews and I like talking to Muslims. Muslims are really cool just because I find that they're more devout. It's easier for me to talk to them because they're very faithful people.
我觉得我最喜欢交谈的人是我喜欢和犹太人谈，我也喜欢和穆斯林谈。穆斯林真的很酷，因为我发现他们更虔诚。和他们谈话更容易，因为他们是非常忠诚的人。
You guys have that in common.
你们有共同点。
Yeah, that's true. But like going along with the Jews and Muslims and stuff is they understand the idea of the covenant, you know, a two-way agreement. So they're more devout with it.
是的，是真的。但就像和犹太人和穆斯林相处，他们理解契约的概念，你知道，双向协议。所以他们对此更虔诚。
At 6:00 PM it's dark and so cold nobody's on the street anymore. So the guys head off on a home visit to meet with a new potential convert. They have three hours of work ahead of them today, and roughly a combined 3,240 hours to go.
下午6点，天黑了，天气冷得街上没人了。所以他们去进行一次家访，去见一个潜在的新教徒。他们今天还有三个小时的工作，总共还需要大约3240个小时。
Jane Feltes is one of the producers of our show.
Jane Feltes是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Four, Contrails of My Tears. We end our show today with this story of a place that is the exact opposite of a tough room. Brett Martin says it's happened him.
第四幕，“我泪水的凝结尾迹”。我们今天以一个与艰难场合完全相反的地方的故事结束我们的节目。Brett Martin说他遇上过。
A couple of years ago I was on a flight from New York to San Juan, Puerto Rico. The movie was Sweet Home Alabama, which you'll remember. It's about a southern girl played by Reese Witherspoon who moves to New York, joins the fashion industry, and then is forced to return home and come to terms with her white trash roots.
几年前，我乘飞机从纽约飞往波多黎各的圣胡安。电影是《情归阿拉巴马》，你可能还记得。它是关于一个由Reese Witherspoon扮演的南方女孩，她搬到纽约，加入时尚界，然后被迫回家并面对她那种“白垃圾”根源。
At the end, there's a wedding scene when the character has to explain to her big city husband-to-be that she's leaving him for her earthy, down-home high school sweetheart.
结尾时，有一个婚礼现场，角色必须向她那个大城市的未婚夫解释她为了那个土里土气的家乡青梅竹马而抛弃他。
The truth is I gave my heart away a long time ago, my whole heart. And I never really got it back. And I don't even know what else to say. But I'm sorry. I can't marry you.
真相是我很久以前就把心交出去了，我的整颗心。我再也没真正拿回来。我不知道还能说什么。我很抱歉。我不能嫁给你。
Into the stunned silence that follows walks Candice Bergen as the jilted fiance's dragon lady of a mother, who, coincidentally, also happens to be the mayor of New York.
在那随后的惊愕寂静中，Candice Bergen走了进来，扮演那个被抛弃未婚夫的“龙女”母亲，顺便说一下，她碰巧还是纽约市市长。
After a volley of insults, Witherspoon decks Bergen. And it is at this moment, somewhere between when Witherspoon drawled, "Nobody talks to my mama like that," and her father, Earl Smooter, raised his face to the heavens and declared, "Praise the Lord. The South has rise again," that something because to happen to me. My face got hot and constricted. A softball rose in my throat that required a surprisingly loud snort to choke back. My breathing grew rapid. In short, I lost it and started to cry.
在一阵侮辱之后，Witherspoon把Bergen放倒了。就在这一刻，就在Witherspoon拖着长腔说“没人敢那样跟我妈说话”，而她的父亲Earl Smooter抬起脸对天宣布“赞美主，南方再次崛起”之间，某种事情发生在我身上。我的脸变得灼热且紧缩。我的喉咙里涌起一个肿块，需要一声相当响的吸鼻声才能忍回去。我的呼吸变得急促。简而言之，我崩溃了，开始哭泣。
I should say that Sweet Home Alabama is not a very good movie. It's actually a pretty terrible movie. I have no particular attachment to Reese Witherspoon, and I'm not from the South. Also, this was the fourth time I'd seen it.
我应该说《情归阿拉巴马》不是一部好电影。实际上它是一部相当糟糕的电影。我对Reese Witherspoon没什么特别的依恋，我也不是南方人。而且这是我第四次看它了。
See, my name is Brett and I cry at movies on airplanes. Not sometimes, always. And not some movies, all movies. Don't believe me? Here's a by no means complete list. Bend It Like Beckham , 101 Dalmations , What A Girl Wants , Daredevil.
看，我叫Brett，我在飞机上看电影会哭。不是有时，总是。不是某些电影，所有电影。不信我？这里有一份绝对不完整的清单：《我爱贝克汉姆》、《101忠狗》、《少女的奇幻旅程》、《夜魔侠》。
Let me be clear. I am not afraid of flying. I like flying. And I'm not a crier, at least not on land. Like many men I know, even sensitive ones who know that having a cry can be healthy and good, I passed some invisible line in adolescence where I simply stopped doing it. There have been many times in life that I probably should have cried, actually tried to cry, and wasn't able to. Because, of course, I didn't happen to be at 30,000 feet.
说明白点。我不怕坐飞机。我喜欢坐飞机。而且我不是个爱哭的人，至少在陆地上不是。像我认识的许多男人一样，即使是那些知道哭一场是健康且好事的情感敏感男人，我在青春期跨过了一条无形的线，就停止了那样做。生活中有很多次我本来应该哭，实际上试图哭，却哭不出来。因为当然，我没碰巧在3万英尺的高空。
Needless to say, this can be embarrassing. I once confessed my problem to a friend, and he thought for a long moment before saying, I'm sorry to hear that. Does it make your mascara run?
不用说，这可能很尴尬。我曾经向一个朋友坦白我的问题，他思考了很久才说，很遗憾听到这个。这会让你的睫毛膏花掉吗？
Earlier this year I was flying from Denver to New York and found myself seated next to a big, burly guy with a cowboy shirt and a western belt buckle. Before takeoff, we talked about football or college basketball or something. Then they announced the movie. It was Under The Tuscan Sun . I glanced at my macho new buddy, thought about watching Diane Lane experience love and loss while rediscovering her inner strength at a farmhouse in the Italian countryside, and read the Sky Mall catalog instead.
今年早些时候我从丹佛飞往纽约，发现自己坐在一个有着牛仔衫和西部皮带扣的魁梧大个子旁边。起飞前，我们聊了足球、大学篮球之类的。然后他们宣布了电影。是《托斯卡纳艳阳下》。我瞥了一眼我那魁梧的新哥们，考虑要不要看Diane Lane在意大利乡村的农舍里重拾内心力量的过程中体验爱情与失去，于是我读起了天际购物目录。
For a long time, I thought I was alone in this. Then a few months ago, I was at a party and overheard another guest describe how he fell to pieces watching an episode of Everybody Loves Raymond on a flight to California. I started asking around and found I wasn't completely alone.
很长一段时间里，我以为只有我一个人这样。几个月前，我在一个聚会上无意中听到另一位客人描述他在去加州的航班上看着《人人都爱雷蒙德》崩溃的情景。我开始打听，发现我并不孤单。
Greg is a 32-year-old guy in jeans and a Mets hat who just finished reading a book about college sports.
Greg是一个32岁的家伙，穿着牛仔裤，戴着大都会队的帽子，刚读完一本关于大学体育的书。
I think it might have been the only movie available was Dirty Dancing 2: Havana Nights. The parents watch them dance and they see how special this relationship is. And at that moment, they've gone from angry parents to sort of accepting of Javier. I mean, I got choked up.
我想可能当时唯一能看的电影是《辣身舞2：哈瓦那之夜》。父母看着他们跳舞，他们看到了这段关系是多么特别。就在那一刻，他们从愤怒的父母转变为接受Javier。我是说，我哽咽了。
As my fellow weepers will tell you, even not watching the movie is no guarantee of safety. Here's my friend, Lindsay.
正如我的同伴们会告诉你的，即使不看电影也不是安全的保证。这是我的朋友Lindsay。
So I was on a flight, I believe California to New York. The specifics don't really stand out. But I do remember that it required a $2 deposit for earphones or something. And I wasn't ready to pay the $2 or I didn't have $2. And I decided I'd read my book. But the movie is playing. And I see it. And I can't take my eyes off of it. So I end up watching the entire duration of the movie without sound. And at various points throughout it I started welling up, thinking wow, I can't believe I'm crying in a movie I can't hear the sound to. And it's Freaky Friday .
所以我在飞机上，我相信是从加州飞往纽约。具体细节没那么突出。但我确实记得它需要2美元作为耳机的押金之类的。我没准备付那2美元，或者我没2美元。我决定读我的书。但电影在播放。我看到了。我无法移开眼睛。所以我最后在没声音的情况下看完了整部电影。在过程中的不同点，我开始涌出泪水，心想：哇，我无法相信我在看一部连声音都听不到的电影时竟然哭了。那部电影是《辣妈辣妹》。
Or take Steven, an avid film festival goer and professional movie critic who can discourse at length on the differences between early and late period Kurosawa. His plane hadn't even taken off.
或者看看Steven，一位狂热的电影节观众和专业影评人，可以详尽地谈论黑泽明早期和晚期作品的区别。他的飞机甚至还没起飞。
And they were just running this loop of commercials and in-flight programming and stuff. They hadn't started the movie. It was very early on. And there was this AMEX commercial. A man traveling through Europe, and you know, I think it was nighttime. I want to say it was raining or something. And this kind of haggard traveller, this businessman, is walking briskly through the street. And then they close up on a wallet, clearly his, that he had left behind unknowingly.
他们只是在循环播放商业广告和机上节目之类的。他们还没开始放电影。那很早。有个美国运通的广告。一个在欧洲旅行的男人，而且你知道，我想那是晚上。我想说是在下雨之类的。这个有点憔悴的旅行者，这个商人，正匆匆走过街道。然后镜头切换到一个钱包，显然是他的，他不知情地落下了。
And then you see, cut to the hotel where he's checking in. And the woman asks for a credit card. And then he pats himself down and realizes he doesn't have it. He goes into a state of panic. I think that's when I started choking up.
然后你看到，切到酒店，他在那里办理入住。那个女人要信用卡。然后他摸了摸身上，意识到他没有。他陷入了惊慌。我想那就是我开始哽咽的时候。
And then he gets American Express on the phone. They explain it'll be OK. He'll have a credit card in the morning. And then I start to relax a little bit. And then he says wait, I'm not going to be in this city. Tomorrow I have to travel. And then I started chocking up again. And then they said, oh, we'll have a waiting for you in that city. And then I just started crying after that. I was so happy for him, and relieved. It was a pretty tense situation there for about 15 or 20 seconds.
然后他接通了美国运通的电话。他们解释说没关系。他明天早上就会有信用卡。然后我开始放松一点。然后他说等等，我不会在这个城市。明天我必须旅行。然后我又开始哽咽了。然后他们说，哦，在那个城市我们会为你准备好。然后我就开始在那之后大哭。我为他感到如此高兴和宽慰。那是一个相当紧张的处境，持续了大约15或20秒。
This is one of the strange features of our problem. We're less likely to cry at the sad parts of a movie, or financial services industry commercial, than at the happy ones, the parts where everything turns out all right. For instance, in the movie Larger Than Life , which I saw somewhere over the Atlantic a few years ago, it wasn't the moment where Bill Murray is separated from the elephant that his dead circus clown father has left him as a means to change his life as a down-on-his-luck motivational speaker that had me reaching for the tissues. It was when they were reunited.
这是我们这个问题的奇特之处之一。我们不太可能在电影的悲伤部分、或金融服务业广告中哭，而是在快乐的部分，在一切都顺利解决的部分。例如，我在几年前在大西洋上空某处看的电影《超大号的大象》，让我去拿纸巾的不是Bill Murray被迫与那头他死去的马戏团小丑父亲留给他的、作为改变他落魄励志演讲者生活的手段的大象分离的时刻。而是他们重逢的时候。
In fact, the first time this happened to me was during one of the happiest scenes I'd ever seen. It was in Big Night, Stanley Tucci's movie about fraternal love and Italian food. Mid-way through the movie, Tucci's character and his brother stage a feast in their New Jersey restaurant, and, at one point, bring out a whole roast pig. The camera pans across the faces of the guests just amazed by this unbelievable bounty being wheeled into the room. And the lump because to rise in my throat.
事实上，第一次发生这种情况是在我见过最快乐的场景之一时。那是在《大餐之夜》，Stanley Tucci关于兄弟之爱和意大利食物的电影中。电影进行到一半，Tucci的角色和他的兄弟在他们的新泽西餐厅举办了一场盛宴，在某一时刻，端出一整只烤猪。摄像机扫过客人的脸，他们对这被推进房间的难以置信的慷慨礼物感到惊奇。我喉咙里的肿块涌了起来。
I found myself brimming over with joy, with the sense that somewhere in the darkness, miles below, just like on screen, people were laughing, communing, sharing a meal. It was impossibly beautiful. And there was just nothing to do but cry.
我发现自己充满了喜悦，意识到在某处黑暗中，几英里之下，就像在屏幕上一样，人们在欢笑、交流、分享一顿饭。它美得不可思议。除了哭泣没别的可做。
I've never heard of anyone crying inappropriately on trains, or on buses, or in boats, or cars. What is it about airplanes?
我从未听说过有人在火车、公共汽车、船或汽车上不合时宜地哭泣。飞机到底有什么特别之处？
I remember getting off the plane thinking, I should really actually be embarrassed by the fact that I just cried during Freaky Friday and I didn't even hear the sound to it. But I wasn't. It's like, what happens in air stays in air, I guess.
我记得下飞机时心想，我真的应该为自己刚才在《辣妈辣妹》期间哭了，甚至连声音都没听到而感到尴尬。但我没有。就像，在空中的事留在空中，我想。
The people I talked to offered a lot of excuses. It's the recirculated air. Your eyes are dry. You're often tired and leaving people behind. And, of course, there's the obvious conclusion. We're all scared to death. But I've been on hundreds of planes, including quite a few tiny ones, one sea plane that landed on water, and one blimp. I've taken the controls of a plane. I've jumped out of a plane. I've searched my soul. An honest-to-god, I find no fear of flying. And all the frequent criers I interviewed felt the same.
我交谈过的人提供了很多借口。是再循环的空气。你的眼睛干了。你经常很累，把人留在身后。当然，还有显而易见的结论。我们都害怕得要死。但我坐过数百次飞机，包括不少小型飞机，一架在水上着陆的水上飞机，还有一艘飞艇。我握过飞机的操纵杆。我从飞机上跳下来过。我审视过我的灵魂。诚实地说，我发现我不怕坐飞机。而我采访的所有经常在飞机上哭的人也有同样的感受。
No, something else happens up there, in that weird hanging state between where you're going and where you've left, where there's no phone calls to take, nowhere to go, nothing to do. Some strange overhead compartment of the heart opens up. And critical judgment grabs its flotational seat cushion and follows the lighted pathway to the big, yellow slide.
不，在高处发生了别的事情，在那介于你将要去的地方和已离开的地方之间的奇怪悬空状态中，那里没有电话要接，无处可去，无事可做。心脏的一个奇怪的头顶行李舱打开了。批判性的判断抓起它的浮力垫，沿着照明通道走向那个巨大的黄色滑梯。
My friend Greg says this actually makes the ride better. Think about it. You're stuck in a seat for 5, or 10, or 15 hours. And how would you rather pass the time? Sitting there being a critic, or just simply giving in?
我的朋友Greg说这实际上让旅程变得更好。想想看。你被困在座位上5、10或15小时。你愿意如何消磨时间？坐在那儿当个批评家，还是干脆屈服？
I mean, I wouldn't have watched Havana Nights in the waiting area waiting to get on the plane. On Earth, no, not a chance. But once you step on the plane, I'm open to and accepting the movie. And then once you do that, it's going to leave me jelly, turn me into jelly.
我是说，我在等待登机的候机区不会看《哈瓦那之夜》。在地球上，不，绝不可能。但一旦你踏上飞机，我就变得开放并接受这部电影。一旦你那样做了，它就会让我融化，把我变成一滩果冻。
My own theory goes something like this. My father once told me that the reason squirrels get hit by cars is that evolutionarily nothing in their little hard-wired brains is capable of understanding a large object is hurtling toward them at 70 miles per hour. Well, even though I fly all the time, nothing in my little hard-wired brain is capable of understanding-- I mean really understanding-- stepping onto a metal tube, hanging in space for a while, and then stepping off 6,000 miles away in a place with different weather, different stars, different time.
我自己的理论是这样的。我父亲曾经告诉我，松鼠被汽车撞的原因是进化上它们小小大脑里的任何东西都无法理解一个大物体正以每小时70英里的速度向它们冲来。好吧，尽管我总是坐飞机，但我小小大脑里的任何东西也无法理解——我是说真正理解——走进一个金属管，在空间里悬挂一会儿，然后6000英里外一个有着不同天气、不同星星、不同时间的陌生地方走出来。
It puts you into a kind of sterile, infantilizing travel purgatory. You're strapped in, given a blanket, a little sippy cup, and tiny silverware, forced to do whatever you're told and borne away at speeds you can't conceive without seeing where you're going.
它把你放进了一种无菌的、幼稚化的旅行炼狱中。你被系着带子，给你一条毯子、一个小吸管杯和微小的餐具，被迫做被告知的任何事，并以你无法想象的速度被带走，看不到你正在去哪里。
We all deal with this dislocation differently. Many times I've thought, why can't I just have air rage? Why can't I be the guy drinking 14 mini bottles of Amaretto, surfing down the aisle on the dinner cart, groping stewardesses, and cursing? But then, I do a lot of yelling and screaming down here on the ground, even a little groping. What I don't do is cry. Not over breakups, or reunions, or triumphs, or deaths, or leaving home, or coming back, or any of life's other bumps and transformations. Maybe that's the key to my air-- what, sorrow? Maybe I cry the tears I should be shedding on Earth.
我们都以不同的方式处理这种错位。很多次我心想，我为什么不能有“空中狂怒”？为什么我不能是那个喝掉14个小瓶Amaretto、在餐车过道上冲浪、非礼空姐、咒骂的家伙？但话说回来，我在地面上大喊大叫很多，甚至稍微非礼一下。我没做的是哭。不是为了分手、重逢、胜利、死亡、离家或回来，或生活中任何其他的挫折和转变。也许那就是我空中——什么，忧伤？也许我哭的是我应该在地球上洒下的泪水。
And all of you people who don't cry on airplanes, you're probably the ones I see sobbing on the subway, or on street corners, or at funerals. You probably get it all out at home. Well, boo hoo. Do us all a favor and keep it in the air, you babies.
而你们这些不在飞机上哭的人，你们大概就是我在地铁、街角或葬礼上看到抽泣的人。你们可能在家里就把情绪全释放了。好吧，去哭吧。帮我们个忙，把它留在空中，你们这些婴儿。
Brett Martin is a correspondent for GQ Magazine in New York.
Brett Martin是纽约《GQ》杂志的通讯员。
[MUSIC - "MOVE THE CROWD" BY ERIC B. & RAKIM]
（音乐 - Eric B. & Rakim的“Move The Crowd”）
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Production help from Eric Mennel.
我们的节目今天由Robyn Semien制作，Alex Blumberg、Jane Feltes、John Jeter、Sarah Koenig、Lisa Pollak、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike参与。我们的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。Seth Lind是我们的制作经理。Emily Condon是我们的办公室经理。Adrianne Mathiowetz负责我们的网站。音乐支持来自Jessica Hopper。Eric Mennel提供制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says that he is absolutely certain after all these years that doing the pledge drive must be good for something.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ的管理监督来自我们的老板Torey Malatia先生，他表示经过这些年后，他绝对确信搞捐赠宣传活动肯定是有意义的。
I thought about it. I was like, I bet selling life insurance is way easier than this. Or like, those guys who sell scissors, go door to door. Like Cutco. They sell scissors. I'm like, I'm sure I could sell some scissors.
我想过这个问题。我心想，我打赌卖人寿保险比这个简单多了。或者那些挨家挨户卖剪刀的家伙。比如Cutco。他们卖剪刀。我心想，我肯定能卖出一些剪刀。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。